kind of a weird story the Church of
Scotland is suing a man who found an
ancient treasure chest on church
property and then sold it
that's a true story that really happened
yeah the Church of Scotland is suing a
guy to get their pot of gold back that
had me wondering what kind of law firm
specializes in a lost pot of gold found
in a Scottish Church have you been
wrongfully sued with nowhere to turn
then call the law offices of mcdougal
McCallister and McClaren I won Tottie's
or the site did a big cricket where the
bra law firm in the whole Bonnie Kwon
who he got your ID because if you're
gonna win weight than a win Whitstable
last year
well that's coming with you dinner first
yourself we'd do it all if it's a mix of
tatak acting a wee Nath brush and God
definitely Wally and public definite hey
my hands mince catch you in the morning
I
thanks to mcdougal McAllister in
MacArthur Han I won my case I think Duke
of McAllister mcclanahan a for mate
named note 6 for 12,000
[Applause]